Now that we've covered monomials, let's make this a bit more challenging. Let's
multiply two binomials. I'm going to start with numbers to give a sense of the
model. Now, even I can't do this that quickly in my head. I actually go about
this another way. I split up 12 into 10 plus 2. And 14 into 10 plus 4. When I do
2 digit multiplication in my head, I'm actually thinking about a rectangle. The
first factor, or side of my rectangle is 10 and 2. The second factor, or side of
my rectangle, is 10 plus 4. Now this is pretty easy to visualize and think about
multiplying the numbers together. I would have 100, 40, 20 and 8. To get each of
these areas, I'm simply multiplying the sides of the rectangles. This one is 10,
and this one is 10, so 100. This rectangle is 2, and this side is 10 because
this side is 10, so 20. Here, this opposite side is also 10, so I have 10 times
4, which is 40. And finally, this bottom rectangle is 2 by 4. So I get a total
of 8. Adding up all of these areas, I get 168. Try multiplying this out and
you'll find it's 168. Pretty amazing. This also makes sense because I have 10
times 10, which is 100. These 1s are really in the tens spot. Then I have 2
times 10 which is 20. Again, this 1 is in the tens spot. 4 times 10, which is
40, and 2 times 4, which is 8. These are for the ones spot. I hope this is a new
way to think about multiplication for some of you.